a bipartisan group of texas lawmakers
backing a new bill to help
ranchers living along the southern
border with mexico recover
from property damage and vandalism
caused by
illegal migrants the act would repurpose
300 million dollars from the
covid funds to help cover crop and
livestock loss
fence replacements and so much more our
next guest is no stranger to these
problems
he estimates he's sustained sixty
thousand dollars worth of damage on his
land alone
texas rancher and kinney county attorney
brent smith joins us right now from
texas good morning you brett
good morning how are y'all doing doing
okay so tell us about the 60 000
worth of damage that you've seen you
know we've had
we've had a lot of property damage our
county is basically at the epicenter of
an invasion
in my view um you know the loss of
fences the
extra personnel cost there's even you
know ranchers in our area having to hire
private security to defend their own
property rights in america
exactly and that's crazy us americans in
this part of texas
don't you know we don't have the same
rights as other people do we can't enjoy
our property
and go in our backyards anymore at night
it's a tragedy well in addition to a
landowner brent you're also the county
attorney there
is currently there's no legal recourse
landowners have to get any sort of
remuneration back from
anybody insurance companies the federal
government which is allowing this
migration
nobody um no sir not this point you know
the security um or the insurance
companies
if it's a stolen vehicle that goes
through the property you know their
vehicle insurance has gotten paid for
and ours won't either so the landowners
are stuck with paying for this
and just on my property loan that we
have here it's over sixty thousand
dollars that we've spent and i know
there's several others on a daily basis
that have
big expenses and not just that but the
livestock that gets down the roads if
you know a vehicle hits
that cow the ranchers consider being
liable
absolutely and you would be on the hook
for that uh some of the damage that
would be covered under the rapid act
is livestock loss as you mentioned crop
loss and damage
perimeter fence replacement damages to
physical structures and property laws
you know it it it just seems brent if
if the administration's going to say
okay we're going to go ahead and let
these people come across our southern
border that they would also
come up with some cash directly uh
to to help you folks out instead they're
saying you know what there's extra money
in the covid fund so just take some of
that
because there's so much of that yeah
well right now and they're bringing
cobia too uh our jail system right now
in our county
is basically locked down because the
jailers and everyone in it has copied
from the inmates oh that's something you
know you were talking
earlier about personal safety uh
and and some people have had to hire
people that
help them out with personal security
when you go out on your property
which is right there on the southern
border do you feel
safe at night
not at all we don't even feel safe
during the day uh
if you're not if you don't have a gun
with you you're you're you know you're
taking a chance
and um it's it's sad that that's the
rally we live in today but you know
we have the laws that are there been
we don't need any new laws we just need
a president that actually enforces the
law on the books and it's a sad day in
american history where
we have to force our president to act
and enforce the laws on the books
well he you know what we've seen he has
no intention
of of doing that part his policy you
know we've heard from the secretary of
homeland security
the strategy is working and and
according to you part of the strategy
is damaging texas land owners property
along the way
that's very true very true and it's not
only a damage to us as landowners
the migrants coming over too you know
it's damaging them
they're being left out on the brush the
cartels are in absolute control of both
sides of the border right now
we have no control of the board there is
no border yeah
well it is a it's a dire situation down
there and we thank you very much brent
for getting up early to tell us your
story good luck to you
thank you